era 1978 y en plena transición
democrática española el fc.barcelona
celebró sus primeras elecciones este
domingo serán las octavas de la historia
para una institución deportiva que es
considerada más que un club necesitamos
un presidente un club como barcelona no
no puede ser que falta un presidente
además del fc barcelona en españa
athletic club osasuna y real madrid han
podido resistir a la compra de
empresarios multimillonarios y
petromonarquías sin embargo el barcelona
con un presupuesto superior a los 1000
millones de dólares es una multinacional
de alcance global que está en manos de
lo local sus socios son los dueños y por
lo tanto la simbología va mucho más allá
generando una gran identificación con
sus aficionados como en el caso del
sentimiento de pertenencia con cataluña
algo que no escapa del debate electoral
igual que el modelo de club basado en
una filosofía de juego que ideó johan
cruyff y culminó pep guardiola pero
también la apuesta por los más jóvenes
en la famosa masía de donde salió messi
cuyo futuro también se cree que pueda
estar ligado a
los comicios en las elecciones por
segunda vez en la historia participan
tres candidatos el ex presidente y
favorito joan laporta toni freixá que
fue parte de la junta de giuseppe
bartumeu y víctor font un empresario con
gran apoyo del establishment sin embargo
las elecciones han estado marcadas por
una convulsa situación institucional el
ex presidente josep maria bartoméu tuvo
que dimitir tras recibir una moción de
censura y esta semana culminó con su
detención en el marco de la 'operación
barça gates su junta directiva
presuntamente habría pagado a una
empresa externa para difamar contra
futbolistas del club y periodistas
además de un posible blanqueo de
capitales